our next speaker is aditya grover uh
he's a postdoc at uc berkeley and fall
21 21
he'll be used at ucla as an assistant
professor
and he's currently a google research
fellow in the probability program
thanks prasad uh so today i'm going to
talk about
uh some recent work at icml on
trying to do fair data generation
without labels and this is
joint work with christie choi trisha
singh
ratio and my phd advisor steph norman
from stanford
next slide please okay so recently we've
been seeing a lot of different
applications of gender and modeling
so we have seen very high quality images
you're also seeing them a lot of
applications of these models
in applications in in in scientific
domains
for example mri for trying to optimize
for
drugs and materials and uh if you think
about all these applications the core
technology that powers it
is trying to learn a general model can
hear the next slide
so we can think of the genetic modeling
problem as follows
so there is some data distribution of
interest so this could be a set of
samples we have from
images from text or from graphs and
we're interested in trying to learn this
distribution
so the procedure that is typically
followed in getting these impressive
results that we saw in the previous
slide
is to think of some model family m and
then try to find some member of this
family
which minimizes some notion of
discrepancy with respect to data
distribution
uh next slide so what i want to talk
about today is a problem which i think
is of
increasing relevance to both industry
and uh as well as territorians here
which is to think about what happens in
the practical scenario where
we might have only very few samples with
respect to the data distribution
but in this unsupervised context you
might have a lot of different a lot of
different data sets which can help us
learn something about this target data
distribution
so the key question that i'll be
focusing on is that how can we leverage
data sets which do not come with any
label information
from different data distributions to try
to then approximate a target data
distribution p data
uh next slide now uh to give a sense of
why this problem
is of interest i think this problem has
direct implications for fairness
so recently we have been seeing a lot of
these different successes of these
models where
you can scrape internet scale data and
then train very large models
but the but the outside of doing such
large-scale training is that when you
look at the
examples that you generate from these
models you see that these
uh samples have inherent biases so this
is a state-of-the-art gender model
that's trained on facial images and we
can see that there's a different
proportion of facial images across
subpopulations which can then propagate
stereotypes
next slide so the
key contribution of this work was to
propose a new density ratio estimation
technique
which then is able to mitigate the kind
of uh the biases that we see previously
in which we have oxidative distributions
and we are trying to see
how they differ from the target data
distribution
without requiring any notion of labels
so uh i'll not go into the analysis but
just to list it out here and have to
chat about in the breakout rooms
we essentially do a bias variance
analysis of our estimator
and show that it scales much better than
previous estimators for high dimensions
and in terms of the practical algorithm
this algorithm requires no label
information from the different
data distributions about the source of
bias
it's sample efficient as well in real
world domains
and it applies in a model agnostic
fashion to large families of existing
genetic models
such as vs scans and autoregressive
models
so this is also a preview of the results
when we actually employ
this technique and we can see that it
achieves a favorable
split in across the two subpopulations
that we care about
thank you